the first pick is on the line chris
we had a little segment earlier a trivia
contest who did you throw your first
touchdown pass to in your career the
answer was michael clayton
now the question is for the first pick
in the draft who is the last person who
caught a chris sims touchdown pass whoa
that's what's the that's what's like
really weird i i'm a football historian
except when it comes to myself i don't
really give a damn about my own
um wow
who is the last person hold on a second
here
um i'm gonna go with
i think it's i killiard
oh
apparently it was in the spleen game oh
was joey galloway in the back of the end
zone joe galloway yeah that's right a
little play action pass we were down
close to goal line i was already with a
bursted spleen but through a dime i mean
through a dime that's all i could say
birth to spleen or not through a dime
touchdown yep no problem
is it bursting or burst
i don't know
i don't know either way it was all
messed up i know that
all right i got to go with tom brady
he's clearly the most important what he
does this off season staying in shape
keeping the guys together all the
workouts that he will
will arrange and gather the players to
have them ready to go
when they are back on the field
officially whatever that may be off
season program maybe not training camp
most likely uh and and the influence
he'll have
in keeping guys there
and convincing gronk to stay
convincing antonio brown to stay to the
extent that someone else may be
interested in him keeping other guys
around and if anyone leaves luring
replacements and upgrades to tampa
they're going to be in a great position
to repeat because he is going to want
that i mean
some will say well okay yeah he got
lucky this year if he could do two in a
row after leaving new england there's no
luck involved and he's going to be even
more determined i think to win it this
year than he was last year well he's
certainly important there's no doubt i
mean gosh the way he's played
you know what to expect of him this next
year at that age and you're right he's
going to have you know something to say
about how that team is built or or stays
together here as far as free agencies
concerned because yeah i mean everybody
who might be looking to go i don't care
i want to play on a team and i'll take
less to go plan a really good team
they're going to look at tom brady in
the buccaneers is like you know that's
that's the number one team i'd like to
go to and that's of course the brady
effect so i hear you there i'm gonna go
to a gm i'm gonna go to the gm with the
carolina panthers i'm gonna go to scott
federer because
they're they're looking for a
quarterback they're looking for a
quarterback teddy bridgewater's
unfollowed them on social media he knows
he ain't coming back they're going to do
something
and i look at that to go what happens
are they going to make a move in the
draft are they going to trade up are
they just going to sit where they are
and take who comes to them at
quarterback or are they going to make a
move here you know and get a guy that's
more established that's already you know
a player in the nfl
deshaun watson so to me that's one of
those i look at because
if they do get a desean watson
or
you know some sort of a proven entity
there that is a team i would look at
like we talked about earlier i just go
watch out there's a lot of pieces in
place there to to think they could be
one of those teams that jump right into
the playoff scene here in 2021 so i'm
going to go with scott federer
yeah and you know i had david tepper on
my list same reasons i feel like he's
the driving force behind this fitter is
the one who's going to make it happen
tepper is the one who is saying do it do
it do it remember federer came from
seattle so you never know when that
well-timed phone call is going to happen
to john schneider if the relationship
between russell wilson and the seahawks
deteriorates over the course of the
offseason that is to be determined next
one for me sean payton i know mickey
loomis is the gm of the saints but sean
payton is the guy who gets what he wants
he shops for the meal shops for the
groceries and cooks the meal bill
parcells style he's gonna have to figure
out which ingredients he can throw
out of the recipe and still cook a meal
because of that cap situation that they
have who do they really need who can
they do without can he talk guys into
taking less what's he going to do at
quarterback these are all things that
are going to be within his purview and
those decisions are going to go a long
way toward determining whether or not
this saints team is still going to be a
major factor both in the division and in
the conference critic yeah i i hear you
there i i really do i mean
listen i i
i'm gonna go the same angle there i i
was gonna i was gonna just go with the
saints quarterback just whoever's the
saints quarterback that to me is gonna
be one of the important things of the
off season who is that going to be
jameis winston taysom hill you know
who's it end up being and then how do
they like you said formulate that team
around them so i am gonna still go with
that because i i don't know that's what
i was gonna pick anyway so i'm just
gonna ride with it but either way
like we talked about too this is one of
the best teams in football they're set
up so now it's okay how can they set up
whoever that's going to be as their
starting quarterback and where do they
go from there and i just look at that to
be certainly like a
a monumental thing as far as dictating
the nfc south and the nfc in general for
my next one i was going to go one way
then i decided to go the other way and
then i remembered when uh
yeah then i remembered what what rich
mckay and arthur blank said when they
had a press conference after firing
their last gem and head coach that
basically where they go from here is
going to be up to the gm and the coach
so i'm going to tie terry fontenot and
arthur smith together gm and head coach
of the atlanta falcons they got some big
decisions to make about the present and
about the future and we've heard the
reports that they're going to keep matt
ryan they're going to keep julio jones
either way they're in a cap mess fonteno
made the rounds last week suggesting
they're targeting quarterbacks are they
going to bring in young guy in what
would be then matt ryan's last year or
maybe two with the falcons well how are
they going to make this work where they
have a team that's good enough for now
but that is building for the future
they're in kind of a weird spot because
they're not far off from contending with
the guys they have the question is how
quickly are they going to pivot to new
guys and fonteno's going to be the guy
who's out there looking for the players
smith is going to be the guy who's going
to have to find a way to make it work
it's not going to be easy to have a
clear vision for where the falcons are i
think of all the teams in the nfl i'm
most confused about what the vision for
the falcons currently is chris i would
agree with that too i'm not sure where
it's going to go i think it's going to
be a big
you know formula change on the defensive
side of the ball like you talked about
with dean pease you're right julio jones
matt ryan they certainly in my mind they
could have been justified in you know
shopping them maybe moving on to a new
era anything like that definitely so
that will be you know very very
interesting to watch uh as we move
forward so i i hear you there i'm i'm i
was that was going to be my next pick
actually and now i'm stumbling on what i
want to quite do here
four teams i think what'd you say
four teams not hard four yeah i know no
i know that's why i well it's hard is
because i want to be a little more
versatile in our our picks but
i still think
when it comes down to it
i'm just gonna go with a general thing
here
the bucks free agents their own free
agents i'm just going to go that way
because again they're the super bowl
winning team we know that they got a
very intriguing free agent list with
some of those football which one's the
most important which one's the most
important which one do they have to keep
shaquille barrett so if you made me name
one i'm going with shaq barrett that's
the guy definitely so if we want to put
one on our graphic that's right shaq
barrett's the guy i look at that will
sway
my thought of them a little bit
if he goes if he leaves i'll go well
that defense is still really good but is
it awesome still i don't know or who are
you going to replace with him so i do
look at him as being that yes that
lightning rod peace and free agency for
them that they have to keep but let
alone they're just their free agency i
think can of course some of those guys
leave they're going to help out other
teams everything like that and it'll
dictate how how much of a stranglehold
they have on the south and the nfc in
general
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports